so
so i'm excited about this this uh um
section because it touches on one of my
passions i'm fascinated by drones um
robots and all that and i was lucky to
meet mrs cummings uh some time ago she's
an mit professor but she has a a
particularly interesting perspective on
on drones and uh and robots because
she's seen
you know all the problems that we could
avoid with robotics messi was one of the
first naval um the carrier pilots flew
a4s and f-18s and such and lands his
landed jets on carriers
and
it's apparently a sort of
medieval and and
inefficient and dangerous um process and
revealed that there's got to be a better
way so tell me a little bit about about
what it's like to let what do you learn
when you land a fighter a fighter jet on
a carrier and what can we do to fix that
well i was very fortunate in the navy i
flew two aircraft the a4 skyhawk and
then the f-18 and the a4 is kind of like
a mg
by today's standards and the f-18 was a
fly-by-wire very fancy highly automated
aircraft and when i was flying the
hornet uh this was in the mid 90s there
were two things that happened to me that
made me realize that
my job as a pilot was in serious
jeopardy and the first one was the
tomahawk missile the tomahawk missile is
a missile that's been used for 20 plus
years with pinpoint meter precision
accuracy
and when a missile and that's what
fighter pilots do is we try to drop
bombs with precision accuracy but the
missiles were always better always
better than the pilots and then
what makes all naval pilots better than
everyone else on the planet particularly
air force pilots is the ability to land
on the aircraft carrier and and then
when i was flying the hornet i saw the
ability for the hornet as well as other
aircraft at the time they got really
good at something called the mode one
approach at the aircraft carrier which
is where you actually set the aircraft
up touched a couple of buttons hands off
for the whole landing
and that was really
humiliating actually in some sense
because that is what made me better than
everyone else that i could do that
myself but yet here the computer was
taking itself off the aircraft carrier
better than i could landing itself on
the aircraft carrier better than i could
and doing the mission better than i ever
could and so i actually took step back
and i saw it a little bit faster than
probably most other pilots in the
military
and i said you know the heyday of the
fighter pilot is over and i would even
be so bold to say the heyday of the
pilot is over
and that's actually when i jumped ship
and went into academia to do research so
you were you were the the the best of
the best you were the the top gun and
you realized there was an even more top
gun and that was the computer itself um
so um that's the aircraft side um
meanwhile there's all sorts of people
scurrying around like ants on the
carrier deck
what did you learn about that
well it's actually a very dangerous
place on most cruises one or two people
are lost because they get blown
overboard on the side of a carrier there
are lots of accidents there have been
some big fires on aircraft carriers
because of the mismanagement of
resources on the aircraft carrier so one
of the things i did and if we can cue
the picture that would be great is in
research we started to look at this
problem
and think about well how could we
actually use automation not just for the
takeoff and the landing component of the
aircraft carrier but actually the
movement of the vehicles around the deck
and
i will sebastian you heard from earlier
he was actually my great inspiration for
this because i saw the work that
sebastian had done
and and the rest of the darpa urban
grand challenge crowd and i said well
you know what uh we only need to move in
in a very small space but it's probably
the hardest logistics problem there is
and i think automation could actually
help change this and help make it safer
so that you can have either some robots
and some humans on the deck and
ultimately where the military probably
will go is to have completely automated
carrier decks can we queue up the first
photograph please
um so what you're yeah so what are we
looking at here so that's actually how
it's done today uh when you talk about
medieval it's um it's almost like a fun
five-year-old game where they actually
move the little aircraft and trucks and
whatnot around the aircraft carrier deck
to get a feel of of how to plan and
where to go and how we're going to
conduct operations and if we could play
the video i'll show you a quick video of
some of the research that we're doing at
mit
so this is basically we've digitized the
aircraft carrier deck and it sits on a
big table top and now you're seeing it
hooked up to a motion capture room and
what this does is
this program allows humans to
collaborate with algorithms developed by
some urban grand challenge people to
actually do a better job
learning how to park aircraft how to
stack them you're seeing them getting
ready to land on the aircraft carrier
basically an air traffic control task
the really unique thing about this
project is what we're showing is you
know humans are doing a pretty good job
at these operations right now but they
do even better when they have the
assistance of algorithms but algorithms
can't do the job alone either they
actually need some supervision to help
reason through some areas of uncertainty
when problems crop up that the
automation doesn't expect so this
research and some other projects we're
doing at mit are really showing the
power that when algorithms can work with
humans the whole system performs better
than either alone so so what is the
future of like we've recognized that
there's many things machines do better
than humans but when you look at sort of
you know commercial commercial air
travel for example what is the role of a
pilot if any
the role of a pilot in today's world is
primarily and i get a lot of hate mail
so you know if you feel the need to
email me just i'm not going to respond
uh is to monitor the system and this is
really this is true of fighter pilots
and it's true of commercial pilots
you're there to monitor in case anything
goes wrong the state of the art today is
that a plane can basically fly itself
and then as recently exp that occurred
here in new york when something happens
and the bird strike chesley sellenberger
was able to take over but and that's
when he was really important in these
times of
extreme emergencies but for the most
part your pilot is monitoring waiting
for something to happen and in fact
what's what's problematic about that and
we see it occasionally pops up in the
news
the pilots are getting bored they're
potentially falling asleep playing on
their laptops
tweeting
sorry uh
texting you know i mean it is a problem
and it's not it's a problem not because
these pilots are unprofessional as the
faa worries
they're just humans pilots are humans
like all of us and when we're working
with highly automated systems and
there's not a lot to do we're going to
find something to take our attention
away so the classic uh comic strip is
that the fact of the future was going to
be you know is going to involve a man
and a dog and a dog's job was to keep
the man away from the machines but
that's we have two pilots right now and
this is two pilots who have basically
nothing to do on on a normal flight
that's right and you'll be happy or
alarmed to know that there's actually a
government sponsored project right now
looking to go from two to one
and you know the expectation is in the
future that fedex and ups and the cargo
planes they will become uavs faster than
we all realize but it won't happen in
this country first because of our
regulatory problems it's going to happen
overseas and then i think once we start
to get
shamed a little bit in terms of other
countries making more money than us in
this area then we'll jump into that game
and then of course the question the
follow-on question is when will
commercial aircraft be unmanned and i
will tell you that
there's no such thing because you're
always going to need somebody on board
to take care of unruly drunk passengers
and so the the unmanned passenger
aircraft isn't really a possibility but
who is doing what on the plane i mean we
could envision a time where the lead
flight attendant was also the lead pilot
right do you need somebody in the
cockpit all the time is there is there a
set of skills that that could be passed
amongst the crew and what about giving
air traffic controllers more power these
are all research issues that are being
looked at right now so we think of
drones as being sort of you know
military technology or very exotic
sci-fi stuff but i mean just just kind
of put things in context um
people here in the audience when they go
to jfk and they get on an airbus to fly
to london um
is there a possibility that no pilot
touched the stick from and from from
takeoff to landing it is technically
possible right now that that is true
that plane taxied itself onto the runway
took itself off flew itself to london
landed itself taxed itself back not
every air not every airport is equipped
with the taxi because you have to have
some adsb technology to give you the
really precise movements that you need
but once all airports have that that
will be possible and that is done in
some airports in the world today so we
fly drones all the time that's right we
just don't think of it that way there's
a reason airbus is called airbus
um
so
we've got we've got um uh just just a
few minutes i wanted to touch on we're
talking about autonomy autonomous
vehicles um broadly now we these are
aircraft but uh sebastian was talking
about cars and beyond i know you've been
doing some work in agriculture as well
and you work with john deere among
others
tell me about the future of robotic
farming
this is an area that i don't think a lot
of people don't hear about because it's
not nearly as sexy as aircraft carriers
and iran captured uavs that make the
news but in fact we have a real problem
in this country and other countries
where we just don't have the manpower to
do the farming that we need and so
what's kind of interesting to me on a
socio-technical level is farmers are
actually very conservative the john
deere crowd you know i i come from a
farming family and this is not a crowd
that generally lends itself to robots
except that they can't get enough people
to work the fields and so if we can keep
the next picture one of the big
up-and-coming uh technologies is crop
dusting and this has already been
happening and oh well let me skip the
head to the tractor
john deere who allowed me to show you
this picture this is a robotic tractor
that's an or it's in the orchard doing
spraying and if you'll note here it
comes
there is nobody in that tractor and then
uh every fighter pilot likes to have a
formation flight going on and what
you'll see is there's one coming right
behind it so that they can actually
collaborate in some sense and do this
task that is very labor intensive but
actually very boring if you've never
seen a current day john deere tractor
you really should because they have more
tv and entertainment devices
in the tractor than you could possibly
imagine it's the sweetest entertainment
suite and why is that because it's
really boring and these tractors can do
a lot on their own and so instead of
that guy being bored in the tractor
cockpit let's take him or her out and
turn this over to the robot so that the
person can do something and that's a
lidar system that's right a laser a
laser ranging sebastian it's it's very
similar to the same systems that
sebastian uses and given the amount of
pesticide that was being sprayed there
it's probably a good thing there was no
absolutely i mean you can imagine that
that this is
you know we talk about uavs for dull
dirty dangerous missions and we hear
that a lot in the military but we don't
really think about well where else would
that be and certainly the farming world
with the pesticides and the crop dusting
that's likely going to take place very
soon in fact the usda is looking at
trials of that right now we're going to
see uavs in our everyday life to support
the food yeah there's a picture of the
yamaha rmax and right now these are
manually controlled to do crop dusting
in places like japan but we're going to
see this more and more
in places in our own backyards by you
know a farmer who can touch a button on
his ipad and the helicopter takes off
and it actually can do crop and health
monitoring as well and it will talk to
those tractors to actually do an
integrated management all from the
armchair of the farmer so i'll drive by
drive by a farm and they'll be robot
helicopters dusting coordinating with
robot tractors doing the harvesting
um
you know we already have presumed you
know the cows are all milked robotically
etc um this is so the solution to the
sort of depopulation of rural america
is to replace them with robots just as
uh japan is replacing uh eldercare with
robots that's absolutely correct and
it's not
it is probably not nearly as sexy as the
military uavs that you hear about but
it's equally or as more important so
tell me a little bit about the
deployment of these um when are we going
to actually see the tractors the
helicopters um i know you already have
manually controlled helicopters
especially in japan but autonomous
helicopters you say the ipad sort of you
know do do the job thing right you know
i actually think it's the
it's the people in this room who will
dictate that as soon as the business
model is made successful and the
technology is is pretty much ready to go
john deere is you know has a few of
these tractors in place in special
places i think it's just making a
connection to the business model how
we're going to do the support and the
infrastructure your how you're going to
call for you know if your tractor gets
stuck how are you going to get it
unstuck so i think we're there we're on
the cusp of that we just need the
business model to be and and regulation
regulation or is it legal
sure you know i i
fortunately we don't have uh the an
equivalent of the faa for farming
equipment except that you're going to
have to look at those legal liabilities
so all the liability that goes along
with vehicles applies to the tractor so
those flying the the the the the k-max
yeah the helicopters actually you know
they have faa restrictions on them and
in fact the faa has it's just been
recently mandated that the faa has to
figure out how to integrate these into
the national airspace but right now that
they're operating it at altitudes that
make that feasible
which is to say below 400 feet that's
right and all that's right you said that
john deere has a couple tractors out
there can you tell us anything about
which applications what kind of they're
actually to do
tilling other farming you know in fact
they they go and they will drive around
a field to actually learn that's what
the the tractor learns the dimensions of
the field learns where to go it's
basically virtual lines that it puts
down on the field and then it just does
those lines and over and over so it's
actually you know it's a step up from
just manual control but there's a lot
more autonomy that is in development and
that will be coming such that you can do
a lot more integration with other
vehicles as well i mean it's basically a
fancy a fancy roomba that's right sort
of right and and you know the natural
question is you know what could go wrong
when you worry about human robot and
you're focused on human robot
interactions when you look at this what
um you know obviously there's huge
opportunity labor savings etc what
worries you
for the farming community that doesn't
really worry me at all because this is
the perfect place for vehicles to
operate you know if they get stuck they
stop this is the great thing about
unground unmanned vehicles is that
anything goes wrong they just stop and
you come out and fix them and you can
remotely disable them
unmanned aerial vehicles a little bit
trickier right and this is in fact why
rightly so that the faa should be
involved at some point because you need
to figure out that for our max the
yamahas
if there's an emergency will it auto
rotate to a safe place and avoid people
i will tell you that in the agricultural
world
again i'm not worried because there's
not that many people out there in the
carrier aviation world safety is a big
problem because we're trying to figure
out how to make planes robotic planes
taxi with man plane all directed by
humans on the ground
that are just missing each other by
inches and so the safety component
is still a major concern in these
tightly constrained spaces and and we
don't have the solution for that but
just stand by you gave me a sort of
prediction of a date when will i first
see this you know robot tractors or or
the helicopters would you you know is it
years or
so yeah you know i've one to three years
one to three years in in america in
america practice um one last thing is
that um you're on sabbatical right now
from mit at the office of legal research
uh what are you focused on now i'm
helping the navy with a robotic
helicopter that is a what we call it
we're trying to put the frontal lobe on
a helicopter developing a sensor package
that allows any helicopter with the
sensor package the ability to be called
by somebody with an iphone who has an
emergency
to bring in emergency supplies or to
take away casualties for example
somebody in the military who's been shot
in the chest needs emergency evacuation
and this helicopter is smart enough to
take off by itself find its own way find
its own landing site in very hostile
terrain and potentially under fire to
figure out where to land tell the person
communicate with the person on the
ground with nothing but an iphone and
then pick that
the trauma victim up and then whisk them
away so let me get this right um
soldiers in the battlefield somebody's
wounded they whip out their iphone
that's right press a button that's right
a robot medevac helicopter that's right
comes lands
takes their comrade presumably gives
them some life support
we have automated critical care systems
inside the helicopter robotically flies
them back to the hospital that's correct
that's the future how soon
seven to ten years is when we're hoping
this will be operational wow
well on that note please join me in
thanking mr cummings
you